Gotta Get It Together
you're embarrassing do you know just how
many scenes were cut from our favorite
Marvel movies and shows what's more fun
than spending a little more time in the
world of these stories learning what
each of these scenes means to the MCU
world and how those hints can lead to
big things like sequels and spin-offs so
stick around for 14 deleted scenes from
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
good to go yeah number one how did they
learn to throw those Thunderbolts the
Cinematic cut of Thor love and thunder
has a few Mysteries that get explained
in the deleted scenes in this deleted
scene a quiet exchange between Thor and
Zeus we learn the secret of Zeus's power
and we even get to see Thor try it out
watching Zeus explain to Thor that
something as small and simple as a stick
can be a thunderbolt some of the big
action of Thor love and thunder makes so
much more sense number two there's so
much more or less than Gods this deleted
scene from Thor love and thunder gives
us a peek into Thor and Zeus's
relationship and gives us a little more
detail of the depth of these characters
Zeus even makes a few nods to how he is
not necessarily a wholesome or pure
character in the planning of this scene
the director and actor Russell Crowe
debated so much on the accent that
Zeus's lines should be performed in that
they settled on shooting everything
twice once with a British accent and
once with with a Greek accent number
three this story weaves so many webs in
an earlier version of Spider-Man no way
home Toby Maguire Spider-Man has a fight
scene with Green Goblin that finds both
on the Goblin glider but this fight
didn't make the final cut we wonder if
it was cut to make more time for the
Statue of Liberty fight sequence
speaking of which the Statue of Liberty
sequence had several different versions
from the one we see in the Cinematic cut
one of which had America Chavez show up
in the final fight number four going up
Spider-Man no way home is filled with
subtle nods and obvious references to
previous Spider-Man movies we get to see
a number of the villains make dramatic
returns and we even get more than one
Spidey in a more subtle moment we find
the Sinister Six quietly and awkwardly
riding in an elevator together we're
thinking that this is a nod to the
moment in Spider-Man 2 where Spidey is
forced to take the elevator instead of
using his favorite web scaling
techniques what do you think number five
secrets of the poster in a previous
version of the movie an early scene was
written where mordo tried to take out
the Scarlet Witch in this earlier
version the Scarlet Witch ends up
cutting off mordo's head and presenting
it to Doctor Strange in a later scene
this nasty sequence of events didn't
make it to the Cinematic cut but if you
look carefully you can see this depicted
in an early version of the poster for
the movie so why did this change the
director said that this early scene was
really great writing but it slowed the
beginning down too much so we had to
lose it fair enough number six keeping
up with the spideys was Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness perhaps
competitively inspired by Spider-Man no
way home no way home was impressive with
how many other MCU characters both
heroes and villains made cameos of
various sizes in the film from where
we're watching it seems like the
Multiverse of Madness creators decided
to up their character Cameo game by
adding plenty of surprise appearances
from classic MCU names now who got the
high score number seven let's keep it a
little happier shall we the ending of an
earlier cut of eternals was originally
going to be much darker than what we see
now in the Cinematic version in this
alternate ending the eternals failed to
stop the emergence on Earth our planet
is destroyed and the cycle restarts with
everyone's mind white while this ending
might have been compelling it probably
would have caused some confusion when it
came to the Multiverse stories number
eight Worlds Collide if you follow along
carefully you'll notice that all of the
events that happen at the end of the
eternals movie are taking place around
the time Spider-Man no way home begins
this means that while no way home's
action Begins the giant Stone Celestial
Tiamat is showing up on the other side
of the planet how will Jay Jonah Jameson
blame this one on Spidey number nine we
need you razor fist in a deleted scene
from an earlier version of Xiang Chi and
the legend of the 10 Rings this battle
scene sees razor fist facing his end but
in the Cinematic cut razor fist shows up
in the post-credits scene where he's
serving Shang Chi's sister so what
happened well we're guessing that
because of an upcoming 10 Ring spin-off
the creators needed him alive so razor
fist lived to fight another day number
10. he almost got to retire in the
Cinematic version of Xiang Chi and the
legend of the ten Rings we see when Wu
formally hand over the Rings Before He
Is tragically taken out by the dweller
in darkness it's a sad moment and we
wish there was a different ending to wen
Wu's story it turns out that this was
not the original plan for him in an
earlier version of the film The Mighty
Warrior survives the final battle after
handing over the Rings when Wu gets to
enjoy a quiet and peaceful retirement
having taken a step back from the focus
of the conflict the director decided the
reason they decided to end when Wu was
because they wanted a more impactful
conclusion to his character Arc we'll
miss you wenwoo number 11. have you ever
had a whistle call for a pet or even a
pal Elena and Natasha did early on in
Black Widow we get introduced to this
charming greeting the sisters share with
one another
[Music]
even when they find themselves more and
more at odds the creators of Black Widow
use this little sound to remind us that
these adversaries were once just Kid
sisters and once again they used the
musical moment to pull at our
heartstrings when Elena visits Natasha's
grave later on in the story in an
earlier version of the movie director
Kate shortland says there were
discussions about including a whistle
reply in the final scene where Elena
visits her sister's grave so when Yelena
makes her final whistle call in her
sister's memory we would have heard a
distant whistle reply maybe implying
that Natasha was still alive now that
would change things a bit number 12.
Odin is that you after revealing Loki to
be masquerading as Odin Thor takes Loki
to New York to the retirement home where
Loki left Odin just like in the
Cinematic cut Thor and Loki find that
the retirement home has been demolished
and you might remember that eventually
they later find Odin in a picturesque
setting somewhere on the shores of
Norway originally the film featured this
deleted scene where Thor and Loki find
Odin living as a homeless man somewhere
near the demolished retirement home we
admire Anthony Hopkins committing to the
role but we also get why they decided to
change the story just a little we're not
sure if finding Odin like this is too
funny or too intense number 13. he
really does look like melted ice cream
in this deleted scene Thor has brought
Jane Foster to Asgard but can't remember
where he put her Thor's obviously
feeling sorry for himself as we can see
in this Moody exchange with rocket maybe
this scene changed the tone of the movie
too much actor Chris Hemsworth describes
this part of Thor's story some tragic
things have happened and he he's decided
you know what I'm just gonna check out
and eat pizza and drink beer and that's
what he's done you know eggs breakfast
no I'd like a bloody mary number 14.
Spidey has some new shades in this
deleted scene from Spider-Man far from
home Peter and MJ travel together on a
plane where May picks up Peter at the
airport but before Peter gets in the car
he asks May what she thinks of his new
look Peter puts on some familiar
sunglasses and while May might not
approve of the look right away we know
they mean a lot to Peter the glasses
were handed to Peter by happy Hogan who
told him that Tony Stark wanted Peter
specifically to have them maybe they
serve as a reminder that while Iron Man
might be gone Tony's brilliant mind
still lives on in the form of the AI
system and his Protege Peter we still
haven't been able to figure out just how
many deleted scenes there are in the MCU
but we love making each Discovery and
exploring each meaning what are your
favorites let us know in the comments
below
foreign